Salut Romain, dis donc est-ce que ...
*rot*
OK...
Est-ce que tu sais si ....
*rot*
Bien.
Est-ce que tu es au courant de ce
*rot*
Ok.
Chapeau.
*générique*
Roter sur commande, pour certaines personnes, c'est inné.
*rot*
Pour les autres c'est souvent plus compliqué, mais ça s'apprend.
C'est même un métier.
Les orthophonistes peuvent apprendre à leur patient à roter,
grâce à une technique que je vous dévoilerais tout-à-l'heure.
Mais avant ça, on va répondre à cette question que vous vous posez, bien évidemment.
"Mais pourquoi diable des professionnels de santé apprennent à leur patient à roter?!"
Hein.. Pourquoi diable ?
Et bien tout simplement pour leur permettre de parler.
Et oui.
Dans certains cas de cancers O.R.L, il faut retirer une partie de la gorge
qu'on appelle "le Larynx" et qui abrite notamment les cordes vocales.
Après cette opération, la trachée des patients est reliée directement
ici, au niveau du cou. On appelle ça "un trachéostome".
Du coup, l'air ne passe plus ni par le nez, ni par la bouche,
et en plus, comme les cordes vocales ont disparues,
impossible de parler
puisqu'en temps normal, c'est l'air des poumons, expiré par la trachée
qui produit les sons en faisant vibrer les fameuses cordes vocales.
Alors.. au passage, les cordes vocales.. c'est pas des cordes.
Il n'y a pas des angelots qui jouent de la harpe au fond de votre gorge.
Non.
D'ailleurs, on ne dit pas les "cordes vocales", on dit les "plis vocaux".
Heu vous voulez peut-être voir à quoi ça ressemble?
Attendez..
Steven mon grand, tu peux venir s'il te plaît?
Aller, montre tes plis vocaux aux gens.
Voilà, donc vous l'avez compris, pas de cordes vocales, pas de parole.
Et bah si. On peut parler, même sans cordes vocales !
Il y a même plusieurs possibilités.
On peut utiliser une machine qu'on appelle un électrolarynx,
que le patient se colle contre le cou et qui crée une vibration sonore, qu'on peut ensuite
transformer en syllabes en articulant de façon classique.
Vous savez comme Ned Gerblansky dans South Park.
"Hello Mrs Cartman, how are you today ?"
Ou comme "Electrolarynx guy" dans "my name is Earl".
Say "Luke I am your father".
"Luke I am your father".
On peut aussi avoir recourt à un implant phonatoire,
qui est une espèce de petit tuyau qui relie la trachée à l'œsophage,
et qui permet de donner de la voix en faisant vibrer le sphincter œsophagien,
avec l'air des poumons.
Eh oui, on a aussi un sphincter dans l'œsophage.
Et il faut savoir que les sphincters, quand ça vibrent, ça a tendance à faire du bruit.
D'où l'idée de la troisième technique, qu'on appelle la voix œsophagienne.
Le principe est simple :
pour produire un son, vous faites vibrer le sphincter oesophagien.
Vous rotez, si vous voulez ..
Puis vous articulez de façon habituelle pour transformer ça en mot !
Vous parlez en rotant, littéralement.
Bon aller, puisque vous êtes là, et que je vous l'ai un peu promis dans le titre de la vidéo, je vais vous faire un petit tuto.
*rot*
Avant de commencer, très important,
roter sur commande
ça nécessite d'être relâché,
détendu
relax,
à la cool,
oklm,
posey.
Bon, ça se passe en trois temps.
Temps 1 : on gobe de l'air.
C'est-à-dire on va faire entrer de l'air dans la bouche sans l'inspirer.
Temps 2 : on accompagne l'air dans l'œsophage.
Pour ça, il faut rentrer le menton dans le cou,
et créer une pression à l'intérieur de la bouche en serrant les lèvres.
Si vous n'... pas à l'..., vous avez encore votre épiglotte.
C'est une espèce de petit clapet,
qui empêche les aliments d'aller dans les poumons,
et l'air, d'aller dans l'estomac.
Pour forcer le barrage,
rentrer bien le menton et contracter le cou en faisant cette grimace.
Vous avez senti ?
C'est bon.
C'est passé direct dans le sphincter.
Temps 3 : on expulse l'air.
Sortez votre menton de votre cou.
Redressez la tête.
Ouvrez la bouche.
Relâchez-vous au maximum.
Ça va sortir tout seul.
Alors attention, dans le cas de la voie œsophagienne,
ça ne fait pas ce bruit là.
L'air ne descend pas aussi bas.
Il reste juste au niveau de l'œsophage.
On le fait sortir pour prononcer quelques syllabes,
puis on reprend un peu d'air et on répète l'opération pour finir sa phrase.
Et ça ne sent pas mauvais.
Vu que c'est de l'air extérieur,
et que ça ne descend pas jusqu'à l'estomac.
Mais si vous êtes dans la performance hein,
ou voir dans la compétition avec des amis,
je vais vous donner mon petit truc perso.
Il faut avaler de l'air plusieurs fois d'affilé,
pour un maximum de puissance.
Mais attention, pas trop quand même.
Sinon vous risquez d'être sévèrement balloné,
et parfois ça pique.
Voilà le dtc c'est finit pour aujourd'hui.
On se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo.
En attendant prenez soin de vous,
prenez soin des autres,
et surtout,
portez vous bien. *en rotant*